(guitar music)
- [Voiceover] Dead Kevin.
(phone rings)
- Global Accelerated Macro
Solutions, this is Ryan.
- Hey Ryan, we need your help.
- Yeah, what's going on?
- The TV's not working.
I don't know what happened.
- Ahmed, I'm at work
right now I can't talk,
I'll have to, I'll
talk to you later.
- No, no we're at home all day,
just tell us how to fix the TV.
- Is it on input four?
- Make sure it's on input four.
- Fuckin' ask him
what set of inputs.
There's about a hundred
inputs in the back.
- There's about a hundred
- Put Jack on the phone.
- Jack he wants to talk to you.
- Does it look like I
wanna talk to somebody?
- No, he's tied up,
he's got cord everywhere --
- He's fiddling with the cords.
- Did you unplug the cords?
- Ahh, fuck.
- Yeah, we did.
- How, what did you do?
How did you do this?
- We didn't want to call you
at work so we tried
to do it ourselves.
- Well you're bothering
me at work now.
(laughter)
Nah, 'cause if you look
at NASDAQ it's way down,
I mean, I'll be working
overtime tonight.
(laughter)
- Wait.
- Wait, there we go.
You see it?
- No.
- Who's talking?
This guy.
He doesn't know a
tax from his elbow.
(laughter)
- Are you talking
to people at work?
- Hey, hey.
Tell him to quit horsing
around at his job.
- Jack said quit horsing around
and he said job in air quotes.
- Tell Jack I'm gonna punch
him in the Goddamn mouth.
- Wait I think --
- This is ridiculous,
what is this one here for,
why is this one even --
- Hello?
- Which remote is it?
There's like six remotes.
- How fuckin' stupid are --
- I'm sorry to interrupt, I
have a 4:30 with United Button,
- With United Buttons.
- I'm gonna need you
to stall Mr. Yoshitomi.
- Stall Mr. Yoshitomi and
I'm gonna get on that --
- He says Yoshatoya.
- No we have, it's a Toshiba.
No, it's a Toshiba.
- Toshiba?
- It's a Toshiba
not a Toshimoma.
- No, Yoshimomi --
- Ask him if there's
a Blu-Ray input.
- He wants to know a Blu-Ray
input 'cause we bought
a Blu-Ray player today.
- You bought a Blu-Ray player?
- Yeah, 'cause we
wanna watch Willow,
Willow came out on Blu-Ray.
- You're gonna watch our movie,
our movie on a Blu-Ray
player without me?
- Willow man, we made guac,
we got pizza, chips, drinks.
- You're a rat,
you're a rat bastard.
- Well, we'll save some for you.
- I really don't have
time for this Ahmed.
- No, no, no, no, no --
- Tell him to plug things back
in where they were before,
press input four and
the cable should work.
If the cable...
Nah it's, yeah it's
probably broken.
- He says it's broken.
- Yeah you guys probably
broke it, just idiots.
It's broken, I'm so mad.
I'm so mad you guys.
(guitar music)
♪ I want you to
like our channel.
And subscribe.
- Oh subscribe, I want
you to like Dead Kevin,
And subscribe.